[Música]
[Aplausos]
traemos hijos a este mundo por amor
no estoy de acuerdo
para nada de acuerdo pues yo no suelo
encontrarme con gente que dice yo tengo
tanto amor como si fuera gordura que me
lo tengo que sacar y tengo que dárselo a
uno
no encuentro esta gente es lo que
encuentro es
generalmente generalmente gente que dice
yo quiero tener un hijo con lo cual yo
diría que no es una ética del amor por
la cual tenemos hijos sino que por la
ética del deseo y otras éticas más que
iremos viendo en el curso de esta charla
esto yo lo escribí en un libro casi
diría que lo cometí en un libro porque
realmente los periodistas se excitaron
como como osaba alguien preguntarse por
qué tenemos hijos pero si es lógico
vienen por amor
los que leyeron el libro y no tenían
hijos vieron en mí una persona sin nada
sin corazón sin ternura inclusive sin
cerebro los que tenían hijos chiquitos
quedaban un poco perplejos y casi diría
el mío es por amor los abuelos con hijos
y nietos en cambio fueron mucho más
generosos realmente me premiaron habían
visto un poco la verdad revelada
o sea todo esto empieza de una
inadecuada lectura de la génesis
fructificado y multiplicaos procreada
abundantemente en la tierra y
multiplicados en ella una invitación a
que no se pierdan este capítulo porque
esto es por amor yo políticamente
incorrecto leo esto y digo esto es un
manifiesto bien bien bien demográfico
sean muchos
multipliquen se sean una tribu grande no
vas a hacer cosas que aparezca una tribu
más grande y los invada los ocupe les
haga daño
la pobreza la pobreza muestra costados
en la reproducción muy particulares y
ustedes dirán este es un golpe bajo
mario este es un golpe bajo no me estrés
la pobreza con la ternura de tener hijos
no tal es así que pienso de alguna
manera que tengo hijos además que los
ricos
los hijos de ricos son son hijos muy
solos están compartan las pantallitas
con vidrios doble escolaridad deportes
papá y mamá trabajan todo el día desde
la mañana hasta la noche lo que no le
dan le dan todo a sus hijos lo que no le
dan tiempo por eso vuelvo a la pobreza
porque 1.400 millones de personas en
este mundo no tienen energía eléctrica
lo que es peor además es que 19 millones
de habitantes en la ciudad nueva york'
consumen la misma cantidad de energía
que 800 millones de personas en la
áfrica subshariana algo no anda bien
dos mil millones de personas somos 7.500
millones de personas en este planeta dos
mil millones
cocinan de una manera insegura
contaminante peligrosa malthus que fue
un clérico anglicano en el 1800 se
estaba preocupado por la explosión
demográfica y dijo que había que parar
esta explosión demográfica porque no iba
a haber alimentos para alimentar a todo
el planeta se equivocó
se equivocó porque hoy somos capaces de
producir alimentos para 13 mil 14 mil 15
mil millones de habitantes el doble
sin embargo mil millones de personas
casi el 20% se va a la cama
a dormir con hambre y lo que es peor el
30 40 por ciento de los alimentos van a
parar a la basura podríamos llegar a una
primera conclusión esta noche los seres
humanos somos seres desechables
la política se entromete en nuestra
manera de reproducir nos bueno no es
ilógico
generaciones fueron diezmadas por la
guerra por las pestes
piensen en el siglo pasado un siglo
extraordinario el sitio de la penicilina
de la informática del aire acondicionado
sin embargo en la primera guerra mundial
murieron 10 millones de personas y en la
segunda guerra mundial murieron 60
millones de personas hoy la la política
también se intrometerse vida tal es así
que en alemania por ejemplo le dicen por
favor tengan hijos y si tienen hijos no
les vamos a cobrar impuestos
el alemán que decidió no tener hijos se
producido por que tengo que pagar más
impuestos para que los demás tengan
hijos
los japoneses preocupadísimos hacen lo
que bolt el crucero del amor para ver si
los las japonesas y los japoneses hacen
japonés y tos e inclusive les financian
los métodos de fertilización asistida
que son muy caros
hay un país del norte europa que le dice
por favor tengan dos hijos uno para papá
y mamá y el otro para la nación
una cosa insólita insólita
también podríamos preguntarnos si somos
muchos o pocos porque y hay algo que se
sabe si un niño nace acá en la recoleta
en la ciudad de buenos aires o en parís
o en roma'
o en londres contamina 160 veces más el
planeta que los niños que nacen en
etiopía como pañales tetinas mamaderas
latitas
ropa juguetes
parece así tal es así que en el colegio
real de obstetricia y ginecología de el
reino unido tenía que hacer alguna
manifestación
para pensar en el calentamiento global y
dijo traten de tener un hijo menos del
que ustedes desean porque los hijos en
etiopía en cambio tienen que sobrevivir
el problema del agua es muy importante
el problema de la alimentación es muy
importante sus juguetes son más
primitivos el dinero
pero como vamos a hablar de dinero si
los hijos son por amor y qué es lo único
que necesitan amor
parece que no me parece que hace falta
dinero de papá y mamá y del estado no
les puedo decir cuánto vale en nuestro
país tenemos algunas complicaciones
económicas y de monedas pero les digo
que por ejemplo en estados unidos cuesta
cuesta o se invierten 250 mil dólares
para que un chico llegue a los 18 años
es más si esta familia además es una
familia que tiene un buen ingreso anual
puede invertir 400 mil dólares y sin
embargo ser un desocupado porque porque
vivimos en un mundo de analfabetos y de
desocupados
se estudió también la felicidad
la felicidad de las mamás que tenían
hijos y la felicidad de las mamás que no
tenían hijos y fue la etapa del time
quien estaba más feliz las que no habían
tenido hijos se las comparó las 5 o 6
años y que es lo que manifestaron bueno
que se habían dedicado más a su pareja
que habían visto sus expectativas
laborales más cumplidas que habían visto
sus expectativas económicas y
educacionales sus estudios las que
tenían hijos no eran infelices pero un
poco menos
hay un derecho para tener hijos
pero en nuestro país se ha decidido que
no tengan el derecho a no tener hijos y
la mitad de los legisladores diputados y
senadores votaron para que para que
ustedes las mujeres sigan manteniendo la
clandestinidad la peligrosidad que
pongan en juego su salud y su vida
porque tienen y están obligadas a llevar
adelante un embarazo que no desean para
defender al embrión pero qué curioso que
todos los que estamos acá no estamos en
cambio obligados a darle un riñón a
nuestro hijo que lo podría salvar
y darle o devolverle la vida qué
increíble que si yo estoy por la
costanera soy un discreto nadador podría
o debería tirarme al río si alguien se
está ahogando para ayudarlo sin embargo
no por qué porque la filosofía del
derecho no nos exige actitudes heroicas
pero a ustedes las mujeres las obligan a
llevar adelante adelante un embarazo no
deseado por una relación furtiva o
porque digamos fallo el método
anticonceptivo o bien porque han sido
violadas por un hombre o bien porque han
sido violadas por una jauría de hombres
alguien dijo que este era el triunfo de
la democracia que democracia tan
particular
en la cual se vota la indignidad de las
mujeres
el consultorio también me dio alguna
letra porque una se imagina en un
consultorio de un obstetra como yo que
traje 11.000 chicos aproximadamente a
este mundo a veces les pido disculpas
por haberlo traído a este mundo político
cuando menos
[Aplausos]
no veo tanto amor usted no esperaba
haberme doctor no la verdad que no yo
tampoco pero lo cierto es que quedamos
embarazados y entonces no sabíamos si
abortar lo tenerlo
decidimos tenerlo yo diría que está más
que la ética de amor es la ética de la
improvisación o usted no esperaba verme
doctor lo que pasa es que si a mi marido
no le doy un hijo varón no para
interesante un deseo sexista y yo diría
18 meses de riesgo biológico de una
mujer para satisfacer a este muchacho
que lleve a su hijo a la plaza a la
pelota a la cancha
usted no esperaba haberme doctor lo que
pasa es que fuimos a una fiesta y
entonces tomamos nos estábamos cuidando
pero tomamos unas copas de más y bueno
acá estoy yo diría errare humanum est
seamos seamos seamos buenos usted no
esperaba haberme doctor pero lo que pasa
es que nosotros dos y nos va muy bien
tenemos las carreras universitarias
hemos hecho la maestría tenemos dos
autos tenemos acá sacan buenos
es mi casa en el campo en el castro y
además hemos recorrido el mundo machu
picchu canalda europa áfrica asia y
entonces dijimos bueno es hermoso una
mascota o un bebé
pero lo que pasa es que tenemos mucho
dinero y entonces si lo queremos dejar
al bebé no a los pobres no a los obreros
al bebé y entonces yo diría que esta es
la ética de la herencia
a usted no esperaba haberme doctor pero
sabe lo que pasa que si yo no hubiera
tenido un hijo me hubiera sentido vacía
esa es la ética del estigma
usted no esperaba haberme doctor pero yo
quedé embarazada en la pareja ya
obviamente se fue pero lo que pasa que
ya tengo 39 años el reloj biológico me
está corriendo
esa es una ética si se quiere biológica
o bien usted no esperaba verme doctor y
viene con la hija con la pollerita del
colegio religioso y le dice no es por mí
es por ella doctor le hablamos tanto
pero en muchachos muy buenos
yo diría que esta es la ética de la
pasión
y varios de ustedes estarán diciendo
corten el micrófono no lo dejen hablar
más quemen sus libros porque nos vamos a
quedar sin hijo
con lo lindo que es este mundo con los
chicos chicos y grandes
yo diría que ni que yo desaparezca ni
que deje de hablar o que hable tres
horas seguidas sobre este tema o que
desaparezcan los filósofos
antinatalistas yo creo que no se va a
interrumpir la automaticidad por la cual
tenemos los hijos la automaticidad por
la cual tenemos los hijos
lo que yo diría es que en todo caso lo
que podríamos hacer es cambiar nuestro
discurso almibarado por lo menos con
nuestros hijos y por nuestros nietos
diciéndoles por ejemplo que una buena
manera de tener un hijo sería
planificada así como planifico un viaje
me compro una bicicleta una moto un
autito una casita planificado
la mitad de nosotros de nosotros que
estamos acá vinimos a este mundo no
planificados
probablemente no deseados a pesar de que
escuchamos toda la vida de que nos
querían
porque lo que yo creo que me parece que
debemos de cambiar este discurso repito
azucarado del amor es por un discurso
que diga en todo caso que traer un hijo
a este mundo
tiene que ser un acto de responsabilidad
pronunciamos
con habilidad para que tengan
necesidades básicas satisfechas muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]